all of us spend so much of our lives  trying to make our future selves happy  we don't stop to ask is it possible that  in 20 or 30 years our future cells are  going to ask us what made you possibly  think that that is what I would want we  don't imagine fundamentally that we're  going to have a different Outlook or a  different perspective that we're going  to be different people if you accept the  idea that you're going to be a different  person in 30 years time you should play  an active role crafting the person you  are going to become you should be the  curator of your future self you should  be the architect expand your horizons  because you're going to become someone  different you might as well be in charge  of deciding who that person is going to  be